emma and i have always
loved each other really i walked into
the room where we were having tutoring
and i just don't know how to say it i
just fell in love with him
emma watson and tom felton revealing
their childhood crushes on each other
was one of the most magical parts of the
hbo max harry potter reunion special and
now the beauty and the beast actress is
speaking out about their close
relationship it feels kind of emotional
actually
in a new interview with british vogue
emma reveals that she and tom are still
close as ever telling the mad quote we
speak most weeks and when it comes to
the potterheads who ship all things emma
and tom it's kind of a million dollar
question well the actress says we just
think it's sweet
emma's reaction to the fan frenzy comes
nearly two weeks after she and tom spoke
very openly about their connection on
the reunion special harry potter 20th
anniversary return to hogwarts
oh look at that look at that
lucky man lucky man
emma and i have always
loved each other really
and while discussing the teenage puppy
love going around on the set the harry
potter stars took a moment to set the
record straight i think i was in the
hair makeup chair uh
and someone said something along the
lines of yeah she had a crush on you i
used to come in every day and look for
his number on the call she was number
seven
and if
if his number was on the call sheet it
was
an extra exciting day nothing has ever
ever ever ever happened romantically
with us
we just love each other
that's all i can say about that
now this romance speculation between em
and tom is not new but fuel was added to
the fire when they were spotted spending
time together in 2019 and when et spoke
to their harry potter co-star rupert
grint about it he shared this could you
ever see the two of them together yeah i
could there was always something you
think so literally the spark and when
e.t spoke with tom in 2020 he had only
high praise for his former castmate i
think she's fantastic and hopefully she
returns the compliment but um
as far as the romantic side of it i
think that's a slytherin gryffindor
thing rather than a tom and emma thing
but um i i absolutely think the world of
her and i think um
i think being
part of what we've all been part of but
for her to be kind of the only
girl certainly the youngest one on set
to grow up with what she had to grow up
with was was incredibly exciting and uh
listen you're gonna get me teary now no
but i i think that she's a fantastic
influence on the world and
yeah relationships aside emma also
gushed to british vogue about the
reunion itself the actress as being back
on set all these years later was quote
like heaven emma also reveals that the
most emotional moment of the reunion for
her was when rupert told her he loved
her when rupert says things he really
means them i was taken aback by how
vulnerable and kind he was deciding to
be so publicly
the little women star also feels the
same way about harry potter himself
daniel radcliffe quote it really touched
me how reflective he had been over the
years about how different it had been
for me as a girl feels strange to be
going home
doesn't it
i'm not going home
not really and although emma reveals
that the trio doesn't text much she does
say that they speak individually and
have each other's support
[Music]